let's think a little bit about how
margin works for futures contracts so
let's say that the terms of the contract
are a thousand pounds of apples for
delivery on November 15th and we're
assuming that this is some date in the
future and right now in the futures
exchange the market delivery price so
the price at which the apples will
change hand in the future is $200 $200
and I've written here what the exchange
specifies for the initial and
maintenance margin we'll talk about that
more in a second but this essentially
means that both the buyer and the seller
for the initial margin have to put up
$20 sometimes it'll be specified as an
absolute dollar amount like I've just
done sometimes it might be a percentage
of the actual delivery price so they
both have to put up $20 and they if this
guy has agreed to buy a thousand pounds
of apples from this guy on November 15th
for $200 so it's essentially 20 cents a
pound now let's say that a day goes by
and the next day these guys have this
contract this price right here is fixed
in their minds but let's say the next
day
this same contract between two other
parties between two other parties the
same contract trades with the delivery
price of one hundred and ninety dollars
now all of a sudden this guy over here
feels silly
he's like man I'm agreeing to buy
something for $200 in the future which
some other dude all of a sudden has
agreed to buy for $190 this guy over
here feels really smart he agreed to
sell something for $200 the day before
and now people are selling it for $190
so he's kind of ten dollars better than
the people participating in the futures
market today the way mark-to-market
works with futures contracts is that the
exchange says well you know what I'm
afraid that this guy if things keep
moving against him he's not going to
even want to he's never not even going
to want to put up the money to buy it
$200 if he can buy in the market at $190
or something lower so I'm going to I'm
going to reset their futures contract to
a delivery price of $190 but to make
things fair this guy is going to be ten
dollars in the hole he's getting a ten
dollar deal if I take the if I take the
delivery pressure
200 to $190 I need to take $10 from this
guy because he's getting a $10 better
deal so from his margin account I take
it from $20 I take it from $20 to $10
and then I place the $10 in this guy's
margin account if he's going to get a
$10 less of a good price on the delivery
date then let me give him the $10 right
now so his margin account will go to $30
now this number was 18 17 16 or 15 this
guy wouldn't have to do anything but
right here he has triggered his
maintenance margin and actually he's
right at our maintenance margin so let's
say that he goes that the next day this
happens a little bit more it goes down
to 185 and we have to do the process
again this guy loses $5 he goes down to
$5 this guy will be given $5 so he goes
to $35 in order in order for him to
essentially reset the futures price he's
been given another $5 now this guy has
only $5 in his mate in his margin
account and the maintenance margin is
$10 so it triggers a margin call and
this guy's got to find someplace to put
another $15 in his margin call every
time you get below the maintenance
margin it triggers a margin call and you
have to refill your margin account to
the initial margin so he has to add $15
so he gets back to $20